[موسيقى]
مشجع المكسيكيه يطعن جهاز التلفزيون
احتفاله للمنتخب الارجنتيني في بيت
مارادونا وبعد شبهات الفساد دي البيرو
يعود الى يوفنتوس هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعون على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
المنتخب المكسيكي كان حاضرا دائما في ثمن
نهائي كاس العالم منذ عام 94 و احد
المشجعين المكسيكيين لم يتقبل اقساط
ريكولور من المسابقه وقام بتحطيمه
بسكين وملامح الحزن باديه بالتاكيد على
وجهه
وفي حدث غريب اقيم احتفالا بعد تاهل
المنتخب الارجنتين الى الادوار الاقصائيه
في البيت الذي كان يملكه مارادونا قبل
وفاته واستقبل الملاك الجدد اعدادا ضخمه
من المشجعين للاحتفال بالتاهل بعد خمسه
ايام من الذكرى الثانيه لرحيل الاسطوره
اعترف لويس سواريز قبل مواجهه غانا في دور
المجموعات بانه ليس السبب في اقصاء
المنتخب الافريقي مونديال 2010 بعد لمسه
اليد الشهيره التي منع بها هدفا النجوم
السوداء في الدقيقه الاخيره من الاشواط
الاضافيه سواريز قال بكل بساطه تسببته في
ركله الجزاء لكن لست انا من اضعها
وبعد الاستقاله المفاجاه لمجلس اداره نادي
يوفنتوس الايطالي رشح الرئيس الجديد
للنادي جان لوكا فيريرو النجم السابق هيرو
ليشغل منصبا نائب الرئيس وكانت تشيكي بابل
نيفيل قد شغل هذا المصري في السنوات
الماضيه قبل ان تفتح سلطه الايطاليه
تحقيقا حول شبهات فساد طالت واداره
السابقه
[موسيقى]